I'm in charge here.
I'm the captain.
Wow!
This is Superfan
vs. Super Fan:
Stranger Things Edition.
Hello, and welcome here
to the windy city
of Manchester.
I'm Munya Chawawa,
here to take
two Netflix superfans
through a whirlwind
of blistering challenges
and gale-force knowledge.
But how does it work?
Well, I'm glad
you asked, Munya.
Our Netflix superfans
go head to head
answering questions
about their favourite
Netflix shows
from these living rooms.
And if they get
a question right,
they move up this board,
slowly edging their way
towards
ultimate super fandom.
But they won't just be
battling against each other.
Oh no.
Each superfan
has also to withstand
these super fans...
How powerful are they?
Well, David,
given a blustery 20mph,
but every three questions
a superfan gets right
will increase
their opponent's fan speed
until it reaches 100mph.
But what happens
when it reaches 100mph?
Well, then,
that superfan
will get super flanned.
Oh, right. Okay.
And I will be controlling
the entire show from here,
the cockpit
of Chair Force One.
I'm the captain
and whatever I say blows.
So show me some respect.
Okay.
I'm just…
I'll hop into here.
One, two, three!
Today,
we're flaying the minds
of two
Stranger Things superfans.
One will end
on a Hawkins high
and the other will be saying
bye, bye, Byers!
But enough of me
waffling on.
What am I, an Eggo?
Let's meet the superfans.
Lily is a radio DJ
from Gosport.
A self-confessed nerd,
she has an "Eleven" tattoo
and loves
her Stranger Things Lego.
Once in Southsea,
Lily got knocked
off her feet
by the wind
from a hovercraft.
She said
she laughed hysterically.
I've got an Eleven tattoo
on the front of my hand,
but I'll now show off
the back...
Of my hand. That's...
Alexis is a belly dancer
from Wolverhampton.
She loves the nostalgia
of the series,
is a sucker for merch,
and her Eleven figurine
takes pride of place
on her car dashboard.
Her favourite genre of fan
is oscillating guest.
Lily might be
the stranger thing,
but I'm the stronger thing.
Welcome to the show,
the superfans!
I know it's all smiles
and giggles at the moment,
sharing muesli
in the greenroom.
This is not
the place for that.
Any trash talk before
we get into the competition?
-I'm gonna take her down!
-Ooh!
I could feel
the venom pouring out,
like a deadly
Demogorgon sting.
Lily?
I'm gonna take her
to the Upside Down.
Ooh, you don't
wanna go there. Ask Barb.
Well, the fans
are all in place.
It's time to play
and find out
which one of you
is a Silly Billy
and which of you
is a Dr. Smartin Brenner.
On your marks...
get set...
blow!
Fangers on buzzers
as we jump
into question number one...
Who gives Eleven her
nickname 'EL'?
Mike.
…is the correct answer.
Maya Hawke, who plays Robin,
is the daughter of…?
Ethan Hawke.
…is the incorrect answer.
The full question was, "Maya
Hawke, who plays Robin,
is the daughter
of Ethan Hawke
and which actress?"
It was Uma Thurman.
So, I'm gonna have to
be robbin' a point off you,
if you'll pardon the pun!
Featuring in the comedy
series Fleabag,
who does Brett Gelman play
in Strange--
Murray.
Well, Alexis, you said
"Murray" in a hurry
and it paid off,
which means, Lily,
you're about
to get a bit more chilly.
Gonna crank up that fan.
Here we go.
Describe the sensations
you're experiencing now.
Windy.
Windy?
Yes, I know the feeling.
Those tikka masalas
will do that to a man.
Right now, it's time for the
Upside Down Picture Game.
So, to start us off,
who is this?
-Nancy Wheeler.
-It certainly is.
Nancy was looking
very fancy there.
Over to the next one.
Who is this?
Bob Newby.
Goodness me!
Is your name Gale?
Because you are a force
to be reckoned with.
Which key character is
played by actor Mark Steger?
I'm gonna go with...
Murray? I don't know.
Now, it is
the incorrect answer,
but you know what?
This show
is all about effort.
So you get a point, Lily.
You're joking!
You're joking, aren't you?
Alexis, how does that feel?
I think I've remembered
who it is.
-Go on.
-It's kind of annoying.
The Demogorgon?
Oh, Alexis,
too little, too late!
Shout out to my girl JoJo!
Right, now,
you might have heard
of the 80s
board game Dingbats...
I know I haven't.
Now it's time
for our version,
Stranger Thingbats,
the wordplay catchphrase
game nobody asked for!
I'm gonna
show you a picture.
Flay your mind
and flay what you see.
Let's see the first one.
Free falling?
Ooh! It's not.
The answer I was looking for
was "mic drop".
-Ah!
-See a mic being dropped?
We're very literal
with this game, okay?
Don't ever question
my Photoshop skills.
I mean, ten out of ten.
Eleven out of ten.
Am I right?
Mouth breather.
And I'm gonna have to get
Crank McCrankyson right now,
because your fan
is going up.
Right. Fingers on buzzers
for the next one.
So, who can you see?
Yes?
-Space Hopper.
-Correct answer!
Well done, Lily.
Okay, back to Quizzness.
Here we go.
What arcade game
do the gang play
at the start of season two,
where they have to save
Princess Daphne?
Is it Dragon Quest?
Oh...
Lily, you were so close.
It was Dragon's Lair.
And that means another point
is heading over to Alexis.
Let me tell you,
if you had a hat, a whip
and a PhD in Archaeology,
you'd be Windyana Jones.
Right, now, sometimes,
Hopper likes
to tell a little porky.
Cheeky!
I'm gonna give you a series
of true or false questions,
and all you need to do
is tell me whether it's true
or a Hopper's Whopper.
Let's see the first one.
Stranger Things
is set in the 1970s.
-Alexis?
-Hopper's Whopper.
-It's false.
-It is, indeed.
And that answer was breezy
like a Sunday morning.
Right, here's another one…
True or Hopper's Whopper?
Bob Newby dresses
as a mummy for Hallow--
It's a Whopper, as well.
Go on.
What's the correct answer?
-He dresses as a vampire.
-Absolutely.
And let me tell you,
that really sucks
for you, Lily,
because that means Alexis
has got another point,
and I'm gonna
have to crank up the fan.
You're feeling more of
a breeze now, are you?
Just a little bit.
Okay, well,
you'd better hurricane
and get back in the game,
because it's time for
another Stranger Thingbat.
Ladies, tell me what you see
on screen right now.
-Yes, Lily?
-Max volume.
…is the correct answer.
Air high five!
Lily, you answered that
just in the nick of time,
which means, Alexis,
your fan
is about to get cranked.
Okay, so it's time
for some more
Hoppers Whoppers.
Is this true
or a Hopper's Whopper?
Season three
has the most epis--
False.
Dustin has a remote
controlled R2D2--
True.
…is the correct answer.
Time for some more
Stranger Thingbats.
Have a look on the screen
and flay what you see.
-Yes?
-Barbed wire.
…is the correct answer.
Well played, Lily.
Here's another
Stranger Dingbat.
-Lily?
-Is it "neighbour"?
Ooh, no, no, it's not.
-It was "Mayornaise".
-Ah!
I'm gonna have
to crank up your fan. Sorry!
Oh, boy. Now, it's looking
quite intense down there.
It is quite intense,
to be honest.
Alexis, looking calm and
collected there on the left.
A bit smug, actually.
Anyway, it's time
to check the scores
so let's break wind.
How are we feeling, Lily?
I'm trying to stay positive.
Go on. Give your little
Eleven tattoo a pep talk.
We can't be pied
in the face.
No, we can't.
Come on. She's been
through enough already.
She's gonna get a nosebleed
at this rate.
Okay, guys,
let's stop gassing,
because wind the end,
it all comes down to points.
However,
I'll tell you this...
I'm in the mood
for double points.
Ooh!
Fangers on buzzers, please,
for the next question.
What colour is the door to
the basement bunker
that Dustin traps his pet
Demogorgon D'Artagnan in,
in season two?
-Blue.
-Ooh…
It is actually red,
which means, Lily,
you're not only
getting one point,
you're getting two.
I'd only do
something like that
for someone who's bribed me
before the show.
Going up two means
we must now
crank up Alexis' fan.
A little push there.
Alexis, you are
blowing up in the world.
Let's move
onto the next question.
What tabletop game are the
boys playing at the start--
Dungeons and Dragons.
Is the correct answer,
which means you go
up another point.
What is the name of Hawkins'
new shopping mall
in season three?
Star Mall.
Oh…
Lily… you're gonna be
kicking yourself.
I know I am.
Star Court Mall.
What shall we say?
Shall we give her the point?
Just give them
a point anyway.
I'm gonna give you a point,
because
I am that kind of guy,
which means
you are now on seven.
Which British singer
is Hopper actor
David Harbour married to?
-Lily Allen.
-Is the correct answer!
Goodness me, you've clawed
another one back.
I thought you were gonna be
Silly Allen, but no siree!
Which of the gang's
last name is Sinclair?
-Lucas.
-Lucas is correct.
Who did Steve put down as
a reference on his resumé--
His mum.
The correct answer
was his mama.
Which means, Alexis,
you've just grabbed
yourself another point,
and Lily,
your fan is getting cranked
to the next dimension.
Ooh.
Alexis, you are now just
three short points away
from being a super fan,
are you excited?
Very excited.
You can't say
you're feeling the heat.
I know that's chilly, okay?
So don't lie to me.
I'm about to show you
a picture, tell me
whose face you see.
-Karen Wheeler.
-Is the correct answer.
Another one
on the board for Alexis.
Okay, next one.
Steve Harrington.
Lily, you know
what happens next.
-I'm just gonna let her win.
-No, no, no.
No, no, no,
you're not gonna do that.
Listen, if you get
the next one correct,
I will give you six points.
Oh, you're joking?
You're joking, aren't you?
He's joking, isn't he?
Just buzz in.
As soon as you hear me say
the first word, just buzz.
Alexis, show
some mercy, please.
You're an absolute savage.
What is Susie's nickname…
for D--
-Yes?
-Susie-poo.
I
gave you a chance.
I reached
deep into my heart.
To quote back Joe, your
fan's going all the way up.
Oh, I can't believe
the last words
you said in this competition
are "Susie-poo".
Anyway, let's break wind.
Well, well, well.
Congratulations, Alexis.
You are the Hawkins High
prom queen
and today's stronger thing,
how do you feel?
Amazing.
You look quite smug,
to be honest.
Just remember,
Lily's about to get
flanned
full speed in the face.
Show a bit of sympathy.
-Sorry, Lily.
-It's okay.
That was the most spiteful
thing I've ever heard.
Anyway,
you beat this super fan,
and this super fan,
and now you win
the world-famous
Super Fan vs Super Fan
super fan.
Begin the super fanfare!
-Aw, look at that.
-Incredible.
Is it everything
you ever dreamed of?
It is. It will take
pride of place.
It's a USB-powered
golden fan.
Poundland's finest.
Oh, Lily.
The whole of "Go-sport"
was behind you.
-Gosport.
-Don't correct me, Lily.
Now listen,
you battled your hardest,
but things got out of hand
and now it's time to get
yourself demigor-gone, girl.
-Any last words?
-I tried my hardest.
It doesn't matter.
Oh… Ah… Ooh!
The squelch!
Wow!
Well, it's
like I always say,
keep your eye on the prize
or you'll get
a pie in your eyes.
Well, guys, two of our
super fans tried their luck,
but only one
truly cut the blustered.
That's it for
the Stranger Things edition.
We'll see you soon for the
next Super Fan vs Super Fan.
So long,
and "fanks" for watching.
Bye bye.
Don't forget
to like this video
and follow us for more.
Bye bye.